yo just that whole like
era of the Lakers was so wild to me
because like I think like you got traded
for Miami
there was like a point in time where
like Kobe was a little unhappy
I forget it was I think it was the year
before you guys got Pau Gasol right yeah
I remember like Phoenix talk radio
everybody was like yo the sons of my
trying to trade for Kobe and then it
obviously didn't happen but if
he probably was bluffing just to make
things happen overnight because that
Chris Paul trade like he wasn't going
ever Kobe would have never left L.A he
wasn't going to leave right crazy what
was it like being on the team when the
league shuts down the Chris Paul trade
well for me I was happy because I was in
a trade you were supposed to get sent to
New Orleans yeah yeah what year what was
that like oh 708 I was
you were in the trade pow was in the
trade
it doesn't happen David Stern shuts it
down you're happy though because you
want to stay in L.A
yeah
was that weird coming back to the team
after like they just tried to trade you
or did you just kind of understand it
was business
nah [ __ ] I ain't never going to leave
early I've been in L.A since I was 19
years old
but I just mean in terms of like that
Chris Paul trade not happening but you
fat you obviously I was happy as [ __ ]
all right I'm saying but you find out
you're a part of the trade it gets
canceled when you come back to the team
it's over with it's over with there's
underneath the bridge knows under the
water now yeah I'm just happy to be back
at that point in time yeah